yeah it's like that you can feel the
glee when they
get to take things apart and i under you
know like i hosted the soup where i
enjoyed
making yeah making fun of bachelor in
paradise because they were
barefoot and having sex and they were
high unrippable and they fell out of the
bed and then their boob
you know like whatever it was like that
seems but when you go like that
then when you see these guys you can see
them enjoying
it right then i'm like all right well
you know
back to the soup you had to take over
for john henson
no well he he left he left and then uh
aisha tyler came in
tyler came in and then it was uh and
that had been on for 10 years
i always think of it as john henson and
then you that's how i remember
no i issued it for two years and at that
point it had already
like talk shows were already waning at
that point so in 2004
it was not even called the soup we it
started out being called the what the
blank awards which was a very confusing
title
and when the new boss came in ted
harbert he was like i don't understand
what that did someone forget it it was
supposed to be like the what the hell
award the what the awards
what the heck awards and so he was just
like don't we have that talk soup name
and then
that became that